well it's all too easy just to spend a
fortune on a wedding and these days
brides are looking for online
convenience and also some serious
savings as kirsten joyce reports they're
finding it with something borrowed
blooms a woman-owned business that banks
on recycling
and everyone knows how i love a good
deal one sprouted for aaron huber when
she started planning her wedding she cut
her floral budget in half as the flowers
weren't real my mother-in-law my mother
they had no idea like and everyone was
just so impressed they were recycled it
was a totally you know new concept and
this very traditional market right
lauren bercier and her cousin started
something borrowed blooms in 2015. at
the time we noticed rent the runway and
how popular that company was amongst
millennial women and we thought it was
such a genius concept here's how it
works the company based in louisiana
ships nationwide into canada once you
reserve your flowers they're shipped to
you three days before your event the day
after the wedding you pack it all up the
return label included brides are looking
for that
just online convenience and we offer
that and it's just another way to make
it a more stress-free experience for
them an idea that blossomed in the
beginning the company supplied florals
for 10 weddings a month in 2021 during
the peak of the pandemic 900 weddings a
month this year they're on pace to do 2
000 weddings each month bersier's goal
to capture 10 percent of the u.s wedding
market i know that sounds aggressive but
i say this all the time if you had 10
brides and line them all up and gave
them the option to rent their wedding
flowers from something borrowed blooms i
guarantee you one of them would say yes
erin said i do several times to
different floral arrangements changing
her mind as brides often do during the
process we were originally going with a
whole different look she finally settled
on the millie collection an english
garden look and it was just lovely and i
was actually able to reuse the table
pieces as kind of like along the aisles
for the ceremony ultimately pleased with
the entire rent and return recycling
process kirstjen joyce live local now
now bercier says the floral arrangements
can be rented up to 26 times per year
and then in between each rental the
arrangements go through full quality
control changing out the stems before
they're shipped out once again